I'm an inbox hero person I try to hit
inbox zero at least once a week which is
the practice of marking all emails that
you've process has done so you get to
the end of the week and you have
processed all of your emails
it is definitely one of the holes in the
strategy where I get lots of Uninvited
inbound information I do have a process
by which my EA's clear my inbox
I have a separate category called not
important where they go through and they
just move all the things they don't
think I need to see into that and I
check it every once in a while and in
the early days every so often they would
flag something is not important that I
actually should have seen but at this
point it's like a 100 success ratio of
them seeing my patterns and typically
what I do is I turn on a loom as I'm
going through the not important and I
say yep these all make sense oh this one
should probably keep in because of this
reason this one we should pull in
because of this reason and then I just
share that to them as feedback and then
the process just gets better
it's probably the biggest hole of people
imposing upon my attention is something
that I'm trying to work on a solution to
I know there have been interesting
companies that have tried different
things like you have to pay money to
send somebody an email I don't know if
those ever took off but that's an
interesting strategy it's like just
adding some friction it's like yeah if
you pay me a hundred dollars you can
send me an email that's okay and I will
read it you know definitely read it if
you pay me a hundred dollars to get an
email sure
so the nature of processing email I
think the way to do it most efficiently
I use superhuman as a tool hotkeys are
probably the lowest hanging fruit for
people to improve their productivity for
almost no cost
how to hotkeys differ from keyboard
shortcuts in Gmail it's the same idea
okay the thing is most people just don't
take the time to learn it there's
several studies on this that I can share
with you but it's like free productivity
you spend a handful of minutes 15
minutes maybe 10 minutes one time
learning what hotkeys to use and most
people will see a 10 to 40 percent
increase in productivity immediately for
the rest of their lives and yet most
people don't take the time to learn them
like it is if you are not using hotkeys
to process your email to do if you're in
figma learn the hotkeys if you're in
Photoshop learn the hotkeys is a free
productivity boost for almost no cost
and in the case of email and you have
reply reply all archive what are some
other functions that you would access
with hotkeys so you know Mark is done I
think one of the biggest ones is
Snippets where you have pre-drafted
messages a good example my co-founder
Casey when she was struggling with email
I asked her to just record yourself
doing email
for however long it takes and then I'll
watch it and give you feedback and this
is the workflow thing where she just
recorded it she shared it with me
and there were many points where I would
say hey during this point have you
noticed this is the fourth time you've
sent this exact same email and you type
it out every time you should just create
a snippet and you should just send it to
them
you see this part here where you wrote a
very long response he was actually
really just asking for a yes or no you
didn't have to provide much longer
context you could have said yeah that
sounds good if you need any more
contacts let me know and I could have
been it you didn't need to spend 15
minutes on that you could have just said
yes and if you need more let me know and
I can give you more so don't make the
assumption that you have to spend 15
minutes on it if you usually don't have
to and so just having that feedback loop
is really helpful and just keeps tying
back to loom is a useful tool for this
but like being able to just see it
in the previous era you would have just
had a coach standing over your shoulder
watching and now you can do this
asynchronously I can watch it at two and
a half X I can skip over parts that are
not relevant it's a it's a really big
enablement tool
and for the sake of clarity
to confirm inbox zero does not mean that
you have handled
all of the tasks or content associated
with those emails it simply means that
you have either responded to them or
moved them into another form factor like
free calendar so that you no longer need
that email vestage you can archive all
that 100 it's reducing that stress that
is created by having this Ambiguously
long list of potential tasks that you
need to do there's no way to see in an
email that I need this from you by two
o'clock today
or I need it from you next month you
have to go through every single one
individually in order to get that
information